what do you think of when you hear of
the Rocks Pirates if you're a one-piece
fan then you probably think of the most
powerful crew that ever existed it took
Goldie Roger to parking himself teaming
up with the Marine hero GARP who by the
way earned his hero title in that battle
to finally stop them and even so it was
arguably their lack of chemistry and
camaraderie that led to their downfall
and not any lack of strength all the
names of the members of The Rock's
Pirates carry a lot of weight in fact
three of the former four Yanko were
underlings in this crew and another Yoko
named his pirate ship after Rock Steve's
epic and all that is just the tip of the
iceberg so make sure to stay tuned since
we'll be going deep into this the hypest
of crews in the history of One Piece if
you do enjoy these one piece videos and
want to keep them coming trailer parking
within and smash that like button until
you see fireworks and if you haven't
joined the nakama today make this the
video by hitting that subscribe button
and hitting that notification Bell to
turn on all notifications so you don't
miss future one piece videos and updates
now I want to thank today's sponsor
honkai star rail the brand new RPG made
by hoyoverse the makers of gentian
impact honkai star rail is now open for
pre-registration just click the link in
the description to do so honkai star
rail is a free-to-play and
cross-platform anime style game with a
wide assortment of beautifully designed
characters each with cool and unique
weapons for example Herda uses a huge
Hammer that can shatter the Earth Below
in Epic fashion while Yan Ching serves
on a sword to attack it just doesn't get
cooler than that I love the costume
designs too especially himekos you know
Sanji would love this game throw in
beautifully animated cutscenes and
breathtaking backgrounds and you get an
immersive experience with top-notch
stories and music that make it feel like
you're in an actual anime there are even
four language voiceovers to choose from
a detail which I love anime fans like me
will be psyched to hear that there are a
lot of familiar Japanese voice actors in
this game as mentioned pre-registration
has begun for this epic game so what are
you waiting for check out the game and
pre register now via my link below now
let's start with some important
background information about the crew
before we get into the individual
members initially people started
panicking when kaido and big mom teamed
up the two yonko teaming up led to
worries of the return of rocks however
at the same time more than a few of the
Marine soldiers have never even heard of
rocks according to sengoku sengoku
describes them as a collection of
individuals who came together on Pirate
Island years ago to make one big score
they were a fierce Bunch constantly
killing one another within the group in
addition to the captain Rox the zebek
they also featured a young Whitebeard
big mom and kaido sengoku makes it clear
though that there were other rocks
members besides the threeanko who went
on to carve out a name for themselves
The Golden Lion the silver ax Captain
John Wang ji and more the crew got along
so terribly that not one of the former
members actually wants to tell the tale
of the Rock's Pirates sengoku lets us
know that the ambition of Captain rocks
was to be king of the world and the crew
opened hostile these directly against
the world government like some kind of
terrorist organization as the government
tends to do it tried to cover up much of
their deeds and to erase them from
history but at the time everyone had
heard of the threat they posed 38 years
ago at an island called God Valley The
Rock's Pirates known as the strongest
crew in the world were wiped out
according to the news reports at least a
rampaging force of evil that none had
been able to stop had been taken down by
a Navy vice admiral by the name of GARP
His Name Was Heard across the world and
he was soon called a naval hero so yes
his title hero of the Marines actually
dates back to this incident sengoku lets
us know that GARP never wants to talk
about this incident one reason we're
given and this wasn't reported is that
GARP had to work with pirates and the
other were given is that he protected
Celestial dragons through his actions so
in order to protect Celestial dragons
and their slaves at God Valley Garb
joined forces with Roger himself there
at the island and together they broke
apart the rocks pirates that is the god
Valley incident as far as we know
sengoku goes on to explain that you
can't find God Valley on a map today and
that it vanished Without a Trace
recently we saw that imusama can erase
Islands as he did with lolucia so God
Valley may have been erased in a similar
way so because rocks was so ambitious in
his pursuit of being king of the world
and he broke too many of the world's
taboos and interesting detail there is
no information in the public about The
Rock's Pirates I definitely want to read
that list of the taboos that rocks broke
sengoku described Captain rocks who led
three of the four former Yanko as
Roger's first and perhaps greatest foe
rocks these epic is also one of those
rare pirates with the the initial to be
fair sengoku does say that 38 years ago
kaido and big mom were nothing like they
are now implying that they've gotten
considerably stronger this does make
sense since kaido was still only an
apprentice pirate at the time however
Whitebeard 38 years ago was 36. so I
feel like that sort of makes up for
kaido and big mom being younger at the
time some other detail Tales to keep in
mind are that The Rock's Pirate Flag
included a red skull with horns it has
also been described as a burning skull
and in a flashback people were in
disbelief upon hearing that The Rock's
Pirates lost and some even said it
wasn't GARP or anyone else that
overpowered them it was just that they
couldn't stand each other no teamwork in
the group was blamed and since the event
is shrouded in so much mystery I think
that's a valid possibility or at least a
contributing factor another detail that
must be mentioned is that despite not a
lot of people knowing about The Rock's
Pirates nowadays Blackbeard chose to
name his ship the Sabra of zebic so
although yonko Blackbeard was only two
years old when the god Valley incident
took place it's clear that there is a
connection there in one way or another
four yonkor connected to zebek and
considering that Shanks was one year old
at the time of the incident he's not in
the clear either there have even been
theories that he could have been zebek's
son but for now it's enough to know that
three yonko worked under him and another
chose to name his ship after him and the
other members of his crew were arguably
no less special so whether people
remembered The Rock's Pirates or not the
legacy of The Rock's Pirates is very
much alive in the world of one piece in
other words the past is not dead it's
not even past now let's jump into the
nine known crew members number one
ochoku also called Wang ji in the
English translation Wang ji was actually
a famous Chinese pirate lord in our
world in the 16th century he was
credited for spreading European Firearms
throughout East Asia and for his role in
leading the first Europeans to reach
Japan in 1543 so the name alone carries
weight but in one piece Wang ji is known
as the previous ruler of hachinosu AKA
Pirate Island also known as full lead in
the English translation Pirate Island is
famous as mentioned it was where the
Rock's Pirates met so you know you got
to be capable to rule over such a famous
hub for Pirates Blackbeard overthrew him
but that's not the surprising part we
know Blackbeard has become a Powerhouse
and is a sliver away from passing Shanks
and becoming the current yonko with the
highest bounty even the dark King silver
Israeli himself said he'd lose nowadays
against Blackbeard so it's not shocking
that he'd take Pirate Island from Wang
XI the shocking part is actually that he
needed help it happened during the rocky
Port incident which happened during the
time skip it was perpetrated by law most
of the details about the incident are
unknown what we do know though was that
Kobe became famous for being the hero
who saved civilian lives in the Rocky
Port incident furthermore Blackbeard
mentioned that Kobe helped him out in
that incident he says it was thanks to
Kobe that he was able to topple Wang XI
and make himself the boss of pirate
island so to me this Hypes up Wang XI
who is clearly a legend from all times
and yet Blackbeard still needed a
Marine's help in taking him down and of
course when one member of the Rocks
Pirates is hyped up the whole crew is as
well keep that in mind as we move
forward on a side note how crazy is it
that Oda can build up so much hype
around an event that didn't even involve
our main characters if he ever came out
with a side story that followed the
incident from beginning to end I would
be all over it but anyways that's all we
know about wangji so far along with the
fact that he was singled out by sengoku
along with pirates like Shiki and
Captain Jon as being worth mentioning
number two Captain John Captain John
went on to form his own crew after The
Rock's Pirates and is notable for his
legendary treasure collection he's
deceased now but yonko buggy is
desperate to find his fabled treasure
cave and their riches within aside for
the one piece itself which we still
don't know the nature of this is the
most hyped treasure in one piece and one
that buggy ornami would no doubt be
thrilled to find after his death John's
corpse was sought after by Dr Hogback
because he was seen as being worthy
enough to become one of the general
zombies for Gekko Moria Captain Jon's
animated corpse makes quite the sight as
he has two swords stuck in his stomach
from when he died I'd love to get his
backstory in manga form as well luckily
in an SBS Oda did reveal at least part
of his history Captain John was
described as being greedy and hateable
to the point that his own crew declared
Mutiny and killed him for it the dude
wanted to keep his large amount of
treasure for himself and not to split
her with his crew so you can guess why
they would be upset still despite being
taken down by multiple stab wounds to
the chest since he was sought after for
the zombie General position it can be
assumed that he was a strong pirate in
life notably Luffy found Jon's armband
among morya's riches not knowing it was
a map to Jon's treasure eventually he
gave it to buggy for the clown yonko's
assistance so buggy May well be the one
to find Captain John's legendary loot in
fact he previously thought it was on an
island with a skull on it but they
didn't end up finding it however another
island with a skull on it is Pirate
Island where the Rocks Pirates were
formed and where Blackbeard currently
rules so it could be that Captain John's
treasure is there and with the armband
buggy may even know it now but the fact
that Blackbeard is on the island has
prevented him from getting it so far
number three silver ax for now we don't
know much about silver ax aside from the
fact that he was singled out by by
sengoku as a member who carved out a
name for himself along with the Golden
Lion Captain John and Wang ji still
based on the company we can assume he'll
be brought up again in the story and
we'll figure out why he was worth
mentioning here for now though he's
easily the member we know the least
about however it speaks a lot that he
could survive in this crew of monsters
where killing each other was the norm
it's actually quite similar to how
Blackbeard Pitt the most dangerous level
6 prisoners against each other in order
to recruit those strong enough to
survive but more on that later number 4
Buckingham Stussy aka Miss buckin recent
events in the manga as we'll get into
have definitely served to Hype up her
character at first we knew her as this
old oddly shaped lady who was obsessed
with Whitebeard she was 38 at the time
of the god Valley incident and now she's
76. she claims that her 35 year old son
and former warlord Weevil was fathered
by Whitebeard this would mean that even
if they met while being on The Rock's
Pirates together it was around two years
after the god Valley incident that they
would have conceived Edward Weeble AKA
Whitebeard Junior honestly as time goes
on I'm starting to believe stussy's
claims more and more I mean from the
beginning it can be argued that weevil's
mustache doesn't lie his hair is also
the same blonde color as Whitebeard as
well as back in the day however we also
find out that Stussy is a self-styled
scientist and is labeled by the narrator
as a mads freeloader notably mads was an
illegal scientific research institute
led by vegapunk this connection does
suggest that Weevil might have been
created in an unorthodox and scientific
way while using whitebeard's jeans
however it was recently revealed that
cp0's agent Stussy is a clone of Miss
buckin and it must be said if Miss
buckin used to look like her which is
the implication it's not hard to believe
that Whitebeard would have succumbed to
her advances I mean we've already seen
that Sanji definitely would have now
from the looks of her clone we can
assume that Miss buckin wasn't just
attractive but used to be a force to be
reckoned with as well we've seen her
clone take out Lucy and Kaku
effortlessly yes she used sea Stone
lipstick to help incapacitate them but
still it's impressive she succeeds
needed in taking two awakened Zone users
out like that the Clone also has
vampire-like wings and appears to suck
blood which in turn appears to drain
victims of their energy and causes them
to lose Consciousness this suggests that
she might have some sort of vampire or
according to my comment section succubus
fruit of course as we saw with the
seraphims it's possible that the Clone
doesn't have the fruit but they just
added these fruit-like powers to her
because Miss buckin had the fruit if
this were the case then miss buckin
could have had these Powers while on The
Rock's crew which would help explain how
she survived in a crew full of monsters
of course it's possible that as an
attractive woman she was protected by
Whitebeard or rocks but I think she
could hold her own after all if she
couldn't why would they choose to clone
her maybe she wasn't as physically
strong but her clone suggests that she
more than made up for this by being
strategic and ready to fight dirty
against powerful men so although Marco
doesn't fully buy the fact that she was
whitebeard's lover I am believing it
more and more Not only was it nice
seeing Weeble protect his father's
Hometown in chapter 1000 73 Stussy said
vegapunk could prove that her son and
Whitebeard are related Weevil before
Admiral Greenville helped capture him
was said to have monstrous strength
which bodes well for him being the
strongest man in the world's son either
way this is a very interesting story
thread and I hope Marco will accept
Weeble as whitebeard's son eventually
and help rescue him from the Marines
Stussy is also determined for Weevil to
inherit the late whitebeard's Fortune
while Weevil really acts like a proud
son unlike Ace and not only protected
his father's Hometown at Great personal
cost he also proclaimed with tears in
his eyes that he would kill Blackbeard
for killing his father while it was
Stussy who told him that Vengeance was
foolish and that what they need is money
number 5 Captain rocks himself it's hard
to talk about The Rock's Pirates without
covering the captain so we went over a
lot about him already while we were
discussing the crew as a whole as
mentioned he wanted to become king of
the world he somehow got all of these
monstrous people to follow him as their
ruler and he was no doubt strong and not
just a figurehead we know this because
when kaido lot of the few people that
could challenge him in strength he
thought of Odin Whitebeard Roger Shanks
and of course Captain rocks himself the
great question is what happened to rocks
these epic could a guy who could not
only survive in a crew like The Rock's
Pirates but even rule over it actually
be killed at God Valley or did he
survive one intriguing theory is that he
succeeded in becoming king of the world
and is actually imusama controlling
things behind the scenes another popular
theory is that he could be dragon's
biological father this would mean that
GARP is Luffy's maternal grandfather and
that Dragon adopted his wife's last name
like Ace adopted his mother's then
there's a possibility that Shanks could
be a son or the possibility that
Blackbeard is in some way his successor
whether that be in philosophy or in a
more specific and scientific way I
personally feel like rocks could have
been the previous dark dark fruit user
and that's one of the reasons Blackbeard
wanted it so bad and yes I just
mentioned a lot of theories and all of
them may be off the mark But as fans we
can't help but obsess over such
legendary yet mysterious figure who was
strong enough to rule over so many
powerful and legendary Pirates he had
his own era before the rise of the
pirate king I mean imagine how strong
you must be in order to make Marine hero
GARP willing to team up with pirates in
order to defeat you considering all this
it's not at all surprising that sengoku
said rocks could have been Roger's
greatest Foe and if rocks truly died
back there at God Valley then it begs
the question would he have successfully
toppled the existing world order if
Roger and GARP didn't thwart his attack
against the celestial dragons chances
are he would have and that begs the
question why did GARP who doesn't like
Celestial dragons save them can't wait
to find out but for now let's move on to
number 6 Shiki the Golden Lion even
though he was a subordinate in the screw
Shiki was also great enough to be
considered one of the pirate King's
greatest Rivals when confronted with
Shiki and his Fleet buggy despite being
a Roger's crew begged for Roger to give
Shiki what he wanted Sheik even wanted
Rogers to be his right-hand man this
clash between the two legends ended up
being known as the Battle of Ed War
sheiky had the largest pirate Fleet
around at the time and Roger was in a
desperate situation and was only saved
by raging weather and even though the
weather caused half of Shiki ships to
sink the battle was still declared a
draw showing how even a subordinate of
rocks could later do this well with his
own crew against the future pirate king
during this battle Shiki got the iconic
wheel stuck in his head Shiki was so mad
when he heard Roger was captured later
that he went to free him it took sengoku
and GARP to stop him and the three
fought until Marine Ford was half
destroyed and he still turned out to be
fine afterwards then two years later
Shiki broke out of impel down by cutting
off his own feet in other words he did
what Zoro was prepared to do but to be
fair it did make more sense for Shiki
who has the float float fruit which
allows him to make himself in non-living
things he comes into contact with
levitate he can make big ships or vast
Island areas float and even make a large
amount of water float around someone in
order to drown them Rayleigh takes note
of his escape from impel down and then
Sheikh even goes to visit fellow former
rocks pirate member Whitebeard he
proclaims that this is whitebeard's age
now but Shiki will lie low for a while
and then show people what a real pirate
is like Shiki felt convinced that with
Rogers helped the two of them could have
conquered the world together like his
captain rocks wanted to do the movie
with him is non-canon so we won't focus
on that here but we'll see if he appears
again in the main Canon story either way
the dude is yet another legendary figure
of One Piece up there with Roger and
Whitebeard and as such he really serves
to Hype up the Rocks Pirates and even
more so to Hype out their leader who he
too at one point served under number 7
Whitebeard and so we've arrived at the
final three members of this legendary
crew the three future yonko or past
yonko depending on how you look at it
yes Whitebeard 2 the man whose era Shiki
said it was the man called strongest in
the world and the man said to be closest
to one piece also once served rocks as a
member of The Rock's Pirates he was 36
years old at the time of the guy Valley
incident he too was considered one of
Roger's greatest Rivals like rocks and
Shiki and man I gotta say Roger had some
crazy Rivals makes sense for the pirate
king I guess after Roger died Whitebeard
was left with the highest Bounty at
5.046 billion which also happens to be
the second highest Bounty of any pirate
in history Whitebeard possessed the
guragura no me aka the Tremor Tremor
fruit UDA stated that this fruit was the
strongest paramecia fruit sengoku
proclaims at one point that with this
devil fruit Whitebeard has the power to
destroy the world the power lets
Whitebeard produce shock waves that can
travel through practically anything air
water and land the shock waves can cause
tsunamis and earthquakes the shock waves
can be unpredictable so allies have to
be cautious around the user and not get
in his way Whitebeard was able to split
an island in half creating a giant chasm
to separate the Pirates on one side from
the Marines on the other he uses the
power to destroy the Navy headquarters
but the power is not Limitless the Navy
has created walls stronger than steel
that won't shatter as a result of the
guragura no me Whitebeard can create
vibrations around himself to protect
himself as well because of this ability
aokiji can't freeze him Whitebeard can
concentrate his power into a small orb
or Quake bubble around his hand to
increase his power he can create
contained but powerful explosion type
attacks he used this attack to beat a
giant vice admiral with one blow he
destroyed his helmet like it was nothing
he can surround His spear with a quake
bubble and use it to extend its reach he
can mow down enemies far away in this
fashion perhaps the most intriguing
power is whitebeard's ability to grab
the air and Pull It by doing this he
tilted the entire Battlefield at Marine
Ford notably when Whitebeard was younger
and stronger his hockey was strong
enough to match that of the pirate Kings
without even touching the Clash of
hockey alone created insanely strong
wins and I haven't spoken about Conker's
hockey yet because not a lot is known
about a lot of The Rock's crew members
but I wouldn't be surprised if the
Rock's Pirates had the most conquerors
hockey users in one crew ever we know
Whitebeard possess conkers hockey same
with big mom and kaido and it's hard to
believe that they were the only ones in
this star-studded crew even though it
hasn't been confirmed roxd zebek has to
be a user of Conker's hockey or at least
I'd like to think so if he could rule
over so many Conker's hockey users
Whitebeard did eventually die at 72
years old but like a true boss he
remained standing nonetheless he was old
and sick so despite how impressive he
was at Marine Ford we should keep in
mind that this was not Whitebeard in his
prime number eight big mom big mom was
30 years old during the god Valley
incident but even at 24 years old she
was a member of the famous rocks crew
this is actually when she met a 15 year
old kaido who was teaming up with the
crew for the first time she comes off as
a sort of protective big sister figure
to him since at one point she said for
him to just tell her if he has any
trouble kaido also remembers her saying
she was going to be king of the sea
according to big mom kaido is indebted
to her she gave him his epic mythical
Zone fruit back during the god Valley
incident anyways the now 68 year old big
mom AKA Charlotte linland as a Yanko
clashed evenly with the so-called strong
creature in the world at the time title
her own Bounty was 4.388 billion berries
but I can't see it staying the same
after her defeat to law and kid big mom
and this goes for kaido 2 definitely
doesn't come off as calculating and
patient as someone like Blackbeard does
she has been known to destroy entire
countries over sweets almost everyone
including her own children fears her
when she's angry she was born powerful
rather than trying to become powerful
when she was five she accidentally
killed a large Bear by smacking it she
even broke the bones of a giant by
trying to slap a mosquito her
overpoweredness seemed more like an
annoyance than a goal at least in the
beginning even as a kid she could break
a skilled giant sword with her fist and
then defeat him I could keep going but
you get the point she's very very strong
and she was so from the beginning her
devil fruit is a paramecia type called
sorosoro No me AKA social fruit the
fruit allows her to take the soul of
whoever she touches and take years away
from their lifespan obviously if she
takes enough years the victim will die
right then and there the ability is
super overpowered on paper but there is
a loophole if you have no fear of that
death you will not be affected by the
devil fruit Powers thus if you want to
even hope to stand a chance against her
you better have self-mastery over
yourself and your fear she can also put
Souls into inanimate objects or animals
these newly anthropomorphized beings are
known as homies and you could see them
all around total land it's nowhere that
big mom cannot put Souls into corpses or
other people the fruit can also produce
little incarnations of pure soul that go
around collecting and distributing souls
for big mom big mom used parts of her
soul to create Three Special homies
later for us we'll see that are far more
powerful than the rest these homies
include Zeus the Thundercloud and is
summoned by her left hand Prometheus the
Sun that is summoned by her right and
Napoleon who takes the form of big mom's
hat the sun can create Flames the cloud
can create lightning bolts and together
they can manipulate the weather it
should be noted that recently Zeus who's
been more associated with nami as of
late than big mom has been replaced by a
new Thundercloud homie called Hera big
mom's hat can turn into a blade that she
can wield and that can move in an attack
by itself her hat can also relay
information to her that it receives from
the other homies homies like clouds can
be written on and allow big mom to
travel at high speeds Prometheus can
also engulf Napoleon in Flames
increasing the power of the sword
furthermore the sword can release
powerful destructive shock waves most
recently during her fight against lying
kid she used a year of her own lifespan
to increase her power even further she
gets even bigger more god-like as she
dominates the panel compared to the now
insect-looking kid in law it's an Ace in
the Hole that she doesn't use often but
as she mentioned it has been decades
since she's felt pain like the painkit
and law delivered to her so she feels
it's warranted she also uses the master
saber combination of Prometheus Hera and
Napoleon to create misery and even more
powerful homie the giant powerful homie
can fly around quickly while launching
fire or lightning attacks in short big
mom and her powers are definitely Larger
than Life big mom can also use
conquerors hockey as mentioned however
the combined awakened powers of lion kid
were just too much for her I don't think
she's dead but she Was Defeated and in a
sense her fight was less Fair than
kaido's because she was double-teamed
while kaido at least at the end was
fighting a one-on-one fight number nine
Rock's Apprentice pirate kaido as
covered kaido joined the Rocks Pirates
at 15 years old it was actually
Whitebeard who invited him to join the
crew after witnessing kaido overpowering
other pirates on Pirate Island then he'd
meet big mom who'd become a protective
older sister to him during the god
Valley incident kaido was 21 and this
was when big mom gave him no me model
serial aka the fish fish fruit model
Azure Dragon more on the mythical fruit
in a bit even before The Rock's Pirates
though like big sis big mom kaido stood
out as being monstrously strong at 10 he
was the strongest soldier of the Vodka
kingdom kaido was so strong and
confident in himself that he'd let
himself be caught by the Marines so that
he could eat their food and then he'd
escape again when he felt like it more
recently the 59 year old man was
referred to as the strongest creature in
the world at least he was before he fell
to Yanko Luffy his Bounty was four point
0.6111 billion berries meaning he had
the highest known Bounty of any living
character before he was defeated by
Luffy people often used to say that if
it's a one-on-one battle kaido will win
when Whitebeard was alive kaido actually
tried to attack him but Shanks interfere
clearly kaido was not only strong but
Brave as well brave enough to go after
Whitebeard that is but how Shanks got
him to turn around has yet to be
revealed he was first introduced to us
as a man searching for a place to die we
are told that he's been caught by the
Navy or enemy ships no less than 18
times but now at least we know that some
of those times if not all of them he was
looking for food he was tortured time
and time again we're told and lived as a
prisoner when they tried to hang him the
Rope snapped when they put him under the
guillotine the blade cracked then he
attempted to take his own life by
jumping off from sky island but he
survived not even kaido could take down
kaido that's how Invincible he seemed
and as with big mom I think he's still
alive but more on that later anyways I
don't know if there's been a better
introduction to an OP character than
this kaido isn't strong because he wants
to be he practically views his
overpoweredness as an annoyance which is
pretty hilarious he has a reputation for
being unable to die despite his best
efforts the first fight against kaido
and Luffy was a significant one we are
used to protagonists fighting struggling
But ultimately overcoming their
opponents however this is not what
happens during the Spurs fight Luffy
hits kaido with many attacks and kaido
is ultimately not hurt by it then kaido
hits Luffy with his Club once and Luffy
is out cold it's refreshing to see that
pure willpower isn't enough to overpower
a strong opponent sometimes it doesn't
happen often in Shonen manga but kaido
was able to brutally embarrass or show a
protagonists and that shows how strong
and special he was it took Luffy
mastering a higher level of hockey
specifically the ability to emit hockey
rather than just coding his body in
hockey and Awakening his godfruit to
finally beat kaido and again I don't
think he's dead but he was definitely
defeated some people even say that kaido
took a bunch of damage beforehand and
that's the only reason Luffy won I'm not
of that opinion personally but it's true
that he did take damage from the
scabbards Yamato Zoro and so on before
Luffy eventually beat him with his
awakened fruit now let's get into
kaido's Dela crew which is definitely
one of my favorites it's a mythical Zone
type fruit as mentioned it's called the
me model seryu aka the fish for fruit
model Azure dragon as a fish for fruit
it raises huge questions like was kaido
unable to end himself because he could
even breathe in the sea even if he may
have been paralyzed like other fruit
users also if you didn't know the reason
kaido looks like a dragon despite having
the fish fish fruit is because it's
based on the Dragon Gate myth where if a
carp made it up nearly an impossible to
climb waterfall it would become a dragon
think Magikarp and Gyarados from Pokemon
the fruit allows him to transform into a
giant and I mean giant blue Eastern
Dragon he also has a hybrid form that he
seems to use most often during the
course of an intense battle he can shoot
heat blasts from his Dragon mouth that
can cause devastating damage he can
create slices of wind that can cut off
limbs tornadoes lightning and even hail
in the video games his Ace in the Hole
is a technique that allows him to
surround his whole dragon body in fire
so that he mounts everything that comes
into contact with him the only known way
to beat him in this case is through
hockey Mastery if Luffy couldn't admit
his hockey he would have had to touch
kaido with his final attack in which
case he would have certainly lost due to
the intense heat we also saw kaido
clashing with fellow yonko big mom as
with Luffy they both use Conker's hockey
when kaido and big mom Clash the heavens
split open just like when Whitebeard and
Shanks clashed that sort of seems like a
sign of yonko hood when you can do that
against the fellow Yanko interestingly
enough kaido and big Mom seem to be
pretty evenly matched in their battle
they eventually decided to team up
together and take over the world so in a
way they wanted to finish what rock
started you see that wish to take over
the world in quite a few rocks Pirates
it definitely seems to be a common theme
and desire in the crew after that these
two plan to finish their fight to the
death however as we saw they were
defeated by the combined forces of Luffy
law and kid before that could happen so
as you can see a lot of Rock's Pirates
members came to power even after the
crew was disbanded now some have fallen
like kaido Whitebeard and big bomb and
and yet The Rock's Pirates remain
relevant literally just recently as of
writing this it came out that Stussy
who's very relevant in the story right
now is a clone of The Rock's pirate
member who herself is relevant now after
her son got taken hostage by Greenville
Weevil is like a rock's Pirate's child
himself since he seemingly came from two
members of the crew While others are
probably connected in ways to the
legendary crew that we still don't
understand at the very least Oda made it
clear that Blackbeard is carrying on The
Rock's way you can see this in not only
his ship being called the Sabra of zebek
but as mentioned in the way he also
prioritized the strength of his crew
members and encouraged them to kill each
other so only the strongest would join
his crew and after going over all of
these characters and their incredible
Feats and Powers I hope everyone
listening can fully appreciate how
powerful The Rock's Pirates were and
specifically how powerful roxd zebek
must have been the man who ruled over
all of these legendary monsters if
you're curious about his successor
Blackbeard and want to learn more about
their connection then you don't want to
miss my all 16 Blackbeard pirates in
their powers explained video link in the
description and on screen right now